you did a real a lot of hard work to
become an actor you started at a young
age
and to me when when i when i look at
this
you know you're going out on auditions
at like i guess
i'm going to say eight years old when
you start i was eight right you make the
decision that
i guess you were rejected for a couple
of commercials and you say as an
eight-year-old
i don't like doing commercials i'm not
gonna do it i'm only doing film
right you announced that to your mom i
guess yes i mean that's a pretty
sophisticated concept you would think
you'd say hey
whatever work i can get i'm going to
take but no you're only a film
actor who the hell did i think i was
yeah who were you that you would even
have that idea
so at how old are you when you debut off
broadway
with ethan hawk like what age are you i
think i was eight
eight years old yeah now you probably
say to yourself at eight if i'm off
broadway with ethan hawk
this career is kind of easy i don't know
what all these adults are complaining
about this is absolutely
right do you do you have this sort of
delusion that this is just going to be
the simplest thing ever
well i already know i mean i i
definitely wasn't delusional because i
was putting in the legwork you know and
i mean i was
i was like i said i was going on a lot
of auditions and i was being
rejected most of the time right and then
you know i think what happens is when
you're a kid actor
and you book a job so the next the first
film that i did was a movie called north
that rob reiner directed and i had a
small part in that and um
you know but when you're a kid actor
it's different than being you know an
adult you know
i think casting directors realize they
can depend on you because you're kind of
a professional
kid right and so you know directors sort
of
look at the reel of actors kit actors
that are already working because they
know that there's a
i think a see a vocabulary that you
understand
um you know and it gives them some
comfort i think at 10 years old you're
at the lee strasberg
school for acting yeah everyone in the
class is an adult there's no other 10
year old yeah
well i i was in their kids class and
then i got um
and then i and then the second year i
moved into the like
kind of older kids class goes kids that
are mostly like 17 18. were you a
prodigy
were you consider i mean you skipped
from the 10 year olds
right up to the 17 year olds did they
consider you as some sort of superstar
even then
i don't know i don't really don't know
what i don't know how i got into that
class
i mean don't you become full of yourself
when suddenly you you're like hey [ __ ]
you 10 year old she's with the 17 year
old i mean
that would be like if i was playing uh
in a little league thing and then they
brought me to the pros
you know what i mean it's like a big
step i don't i don't know
i don't think i was full of myself but
it's hard to remember i mean i'm an
actor so obviously there's a certain
level of narcissism were the other
people at least strasbourg uh were they
jealous of you because you had been off
broadway and like you said you already
were cast in uh rob reiner's north
right yeah i mean which was at the time
you know probably rob reiner he had had
a string of hits
yeah i mean he was one of the biggest
directors yeah it was a good time for
him i don't know i mean i don't remember
kids being particularly mean to me but
maybe that's just because i was
you know uh i i don't know i was i was a
pretty low-key kid i
i wasn't very flashy or showy or
anything when you go to regular school
though and you're not at least
to a regular public school but for me
like who went to see
sophistry with ethan hawk off broadway
like nobody gave a [ __ ]
you know what i mean were you as a as a
little girl were you just enamored with
ethan hawk
i was enamored with ethan hoffman yeah i
mean oh my god totally i was just
absolutely never and this was you know i
don't know 90 whatever
95 or something like that so that was
that was prime because he represents
what you wanted to be right
he was a successful working actor that
he was also gorgeous and like this you
know guy and young guy in his 20s that
was like
you know smoking four cigarettes at once
and it's like his
tingle was flipped backwards or whatever
do you still know ethan hawke is that a
relationship
i do i mean it's so funny to see him of
course now she's like you're that little
girl i
i acted with right yeah yeah it's got to
be weird it must be weird because i have
boobs now